boxing has massively helped my mental
health most of the people here probably
won't even have jobs if they didn't go
here because they wouldn't have like the
right state in mind it helps create that
sense of belonging without I don't know
where I'd be
taking part in any physical activity
regularly will positively impact on a
person's physical and mental well-being
boxing has really high physical demands
so if a young person engages in boxing
training on a regular basis and they put
the effort in they'll probably see
improved muscular strength improve
muscular power and improvements in their
anaerobic Fitness
[Music]
boxing is massively disciplined me I've
lost 10 kilos in weight I've been eating
healthy I haven't drunk
boxing keeps me forecast it keeps me fit
it keeps me healthy body and mind boxing
can also alleviate some of the symptoms
of anxiety and depression
the Bulldogs is a boxing gym based in
Port Talbot we're here to support the
local community
we've got people from all walks of life
different backgrounds we've got people
at home are disengaged with Society some
people who are disengage with school
with some people who have been on the
wrong side of the law
it helps create a sense of identity
through attending a gym and training
with others and overall it helps create
that sense of belonging
the benefits of boxing in corporate
things such as cooperation and teamwork
even though boxing may seem an
individual sport is very much involves
working with a coach or a group of
coaches as well as other people within a
gym
and ultimately it's really a place to
reinstill some discipline into them and
put them back on the on the street
dinaro foreign
there's a lot of misconceptions about
the title but you know they talk about
the steel works all the air about this
and that there's not much opportunity
here but there's a lot of talent there's
a lot of sport
and there is a sense of community a
what happens with most buys what
happened to me is 16 17. got him with
the wrong crowd started drinking started
doing this and that and so I lost my way
I guess she did some of the issues with
Sam's being and I see myself in him
struggling really for
somewhere to go somewhere to see and
probably somebody feel accepted
[Music]
it was very important to to be able to
build and gain the trust and respect of
the young individuals who come here it's
about being available it's about
mentoring coaching empowering and also
developing their needs because a lot of
these young people haven't actually been
able to trust people before
we all respect the coaches because we
want them to coach us and not for them
to shout at us and they kick us out
the people I knew are like a family that
I've never met before like you're really
close to them like no matter what they
can talk to you even if you're feeling
down and they've always got your back
[Music]
some people feel that it can actually
increase aggression and violence but
research shows that it actually has the
opposite effect so it teaches young
people to react differently in
situations that would normally trigger
the anger and these stress responses
obviously with a sport like boxing
there's the risks of physical injury
particularly when you're sparring and
particularly when you're competing
however one could argue that the
benefits do actually outweigh these
risks foreign
[Music]
boxing is massively disciplined me made
me work hard resilient core values you
need in your life to progress they come
here they can speak to people they're
gonna let their frustrations go and you
know really have a different outlooking
perspective on life I think it's very
important and that sense of identity can
extend beyond the boxing gym so not just
to the gym itself but also to The Wider
community and The Wider Town Village or
Society where that individual lives the
football laws give me my first
opportunity to be a leader teacher and
now I'm going on to finish my degree and
be a qualified teacher
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video